Le'ts take a look at the 4-ary trie where
k equals 2. Suppose we have the same forwarding table
as before. But now, each node in the trie is
responsible for resolving two bits. So if we take one
one, and now we take one star, that's one zero
and one one. And now we basically have to put
p1. In two places in the tree. One zero star
results in just one entry. 1010 star results in two
traversals, and 10101 star again represents two
entries, for 101010 and 101011. Now suppose we
want to look up 10111. Again, we can spell this out. 101 and
we can see that we get no further than P2 and again, that we
match at P2. One thing we can do to save space further is create
what's called a leaf-pushed trie. In such a
setting, we can save our self some space.
Instead of having these pointers. We can push
these entries into the left and right side
of this note, respectively. So 10 becomes P1 on the left side and 11 becomes P1
on the right side. There are variety of
other atomization algorithms. Including one called Lulea and another
called Patricia. Each of them use the same basic idea
that we have explored here, except some of them like Lulea
are a three level trie, and often they use a bitmap
to compress out repeated entry such as those that exist here.